- Are you going to eat that?
- Are you going to the cock?
(upbeat music)
- Today we're playing
the whisper challenge.
- This was popular amongst
YouTubers a little bit ago,
but the producers thought it was funny
so we're gonna do it now.
- I'm Chaley.
- Carlos, nice to meet you.
- Carlos, nice to meet you man.
- Hi.
- Hey.
- I'm Angie.
- My name is Elisa.
- I'm Gia.
- I'm Michael.
Nice to meet you.
- It's nice to meet you.
- How is it?
Is it loud enough?
- It's piano.
- I'm talking really loud now I know.
- Yeah.
- Wieners.
- I can't hear shit.
- Penis.
- What?
- A rat cleans his house
with his tiny family.
- Something house where our family is.
- I would like a monocle please.
- Can I murder you please?
(laughing)
- A rat cleans his house
with his tiny family.
- Rent.
- Rat.
- Right.
Like mice.
- Like best.
- Mice.
- Best.
- What?
- I would like a monocle please.
- Hi, can I have some watermelon please?
(laughing)
- It was a rat cleans his
house up with his tiny family.
- Wow.
- I would like a monocle please.
- What the fuck?
(laughing)
- You can't look.
- Okay, shit.
- There's always a
rainbow after the storm.
- You're bringing the
puppies down to the lake.
- There's always a
rainbow after the tacos.
- You need to get the
fuck out of my house.
(laughing)
- Sally sells seashells by the seashore.
- Santa salad.
Salad, okay salad.
- No, no, no, no.
Sally.
- There's always--
- A rainbow.
- There's always a free boat.
(laughing)
There's always a rainbow.
- After.
- A storm.
A storm.
- After a big celebration.
(laughing)
- Sally sells.
- Sally tells.
- Sells, like.
- Oh type.
- No, no, no.
Sally sells seashells by the seashore.
- I give up.
- Tough one.
- There's always a
rainbow after the storm.
(laughing)
- Later tonight I'm going
to go get vegan food.
- That was really inappropriate.
- If you like meat.
- I would like a monocle please.
- Oh god.
I really like bottles please.
- Close, close.
- I feel like I'm very loud.
- You are.
- Okay.
(laughing)
- Noodles.
- Losers.
- Noodles, noodles.
- You.
I'm not getting this.
- Noodles.
- Use.
- I would like.
- A monocle.
- A bottle.
- A bongle.
- A boggle.
- Noodles, noodles, noodles.
- Lose, no.
You.
I, me.
- Later tonight, I'm
gonna go get vegan food.
- You were gonna do coke in the fields.
(laughing)
- It's noodles, noodles, noodles.
- Oh, okay, okay.
- I would like a monocle.
- A monocle.
What?
- That was horrible, honestly.
- It was fun.
It was reminding me of the telephone.
- Yeah.
- When they whisper that in your ear.
- Exactly.
- Same concept.
- It was quite hard.
- Based on a one through
10 I think it was like...
- Eight.
- 8.5 for me.
- Yeah, the most fun was
guessing what he was saying
because I literally had no idea,
so I could just make up words.
- It was fun.
- I liked it.
- New best friend?
- Yeah.
- What's your name again?
I'm just kidding.
(laughing)